dos reuniones maratonianas hoy aquí en
bruselas para abordar la invasión de
ucrania por parte de rusia primero los
cancilleres de la otan se han reunido
para acordar que hay que reforzar el
flanco oriental ante esta invasión pero
por otra parte han rechazado la creación
de una zona de exclusión aérea tal y
como pide el gobierno ucraniano el
secretario general de la otan y el
stoltenberg asegura que si se aceptará
esto provocaría una guerra total con
ucrania que que la otan quiere evitar a
toda costa además se ha acordado ampliar
la coordinación con finlandia y suecia
recordemos dos países que no forman
parte de la alianza pero que a partir de
ahora formarán parte de todas las
reuniones en las que se aborde el
conflicto tras esta reunión los
cancilleres de la unión europea han
llegado aquí a este edificio al consejo
de la unión europea también para abordar
esta invasión a la que también han
invitado al secretario de estado
norteamericano anthony blinken entre las
cuestiones que se han han discutido está
la posibilidad de ampliar las sanciones
financieras como por ejemplo que haya
más bancos rusos que se eliminen del
sistema swift recordemos hasta ahora en
las sanciones hay siete bancos rusos por
otra parte el jefe de la diplomacia
europea josep borrell ha asegurado que
todo está encima de la mesa y entre ello
también la de reducir las importaciones
de gas provenientes de rusia recordemos
el grueso de los beneficios que obtiene
el país provienen de las exportaciones
de gas